.
>> Dana: GREAT.
>> Bill: KEEPING SCORE, RIGHT?
AN ESTIMATED 50,000 MIGRANTS
SEEKING ASYLUM WAITING IN MEXICO
NOW PLANNING TO CROSS THE BORDER
AS SOON AS TITLE 42 ENDS.
THE NUMBER OF ILLEGAL CROSSINGS
COULD DOUBLE OR EVEN TRIPLE IN
THE COMING DAYS WITH NO CLEAR
PLAN FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO
STEM THE TIDE.
SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY SAYING
REPUBLICANS HAVE LOST TRUST IN
THE WILLINGNESS OF THE WHITE
HOUSE TO SECURE THE BORDER AMID
RECORD ILLEGAL CROSSINGS.
>> THE PRESIDENT OUGHT TO HAVE
HIS HEAD IN A BAG.
IT IS CLEAR THAT HE AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE ADMINISTRATION
ARE PERFECTLY CONTENT TO HAVE AN
OPEN BORDER.
ALL PRESIDENT BIDEN NEEDS TO DO
IN ORDER TO SECURE THE BORDER IS
GO BACK DOING WHAT WE WERE
DOING.
>> Dana: BILL MELUGIN IS LIVE IN
EAGLE PASS, TEXAS.
I'M SURE THE LOCAL COMMUNITY IS
BRACING ITSELF FOR WHAT'S TO
COME, BILL.
>> THEY ARE.
GOOD MORNING.
AS USUAL, AS SOON AS THE SUN
CAME UP THIS MORNING WE STARTED
GETTING MASS ILLEGAL CROSSINGS
HERE.
TAKE YOU LIVE TO OUR FOX DRONE
RIGHT NOW.
A COUPLE MILES AWAY FROM WHERE
I'M STANDING RIGHT NOW IN EAGLE
PASS.
IT IS OVER A GROUP OF SEVERAL
HUNDRED WHO HAVE JUST CROSSED
ILLEGALLY STANDING AROUND
WAITING FOR PROCESSING AND
TRANSPORT BY BORDER CONTROL.
THE RIVER WHERE THEY CROSSED IS
A PRIVATE PECAN ORCHARD.
PRIVATE PROPERTY AND WHY THE
STATE OF TEXAS PUT UP A CHAIN
LINK FENCE.
THEY CLAIM OVER IT OR WALK
THROUGH IT.
YOU CAN SEE THE AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES THAT HAVE TO RESPOND
TO A GROUP LIKE THIS.
SHOW YOU THE GROUP AS IT WAS
WALKING UP.
LOOK AT THIS PIECE OF VIDEO OUR
TEAM SHOT JUST AFTER SUNRISE,
THE LOW SUNLIGHT AS THE GROUP
WALKS PAST THE CHAIN LINK FENCE.
CUBANS, NICARAGUANS AND
COLUMBIANS.
MOST NOT SUBJECT TO TITLE 42.
THIS DEL RIO SECTOR THAT
INCLUDES EAGLE PASS HAS ALREADY
SEEN OVER 115,000 ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS JUST SINCE
OCTOBER 1ST.
THE NUMBERS ARE UP 56% OVER THE
SAME TIME LAST YEAR.
LAST YEAR SET THE ALL-TIME
RECORD FOR ILLEGAL CROSSINGS IN
THIS SECTOR.
WE'RE ALREADY ON TRACK TO BLOW
THAT RECORD OUT OF THE WATER
JUST 2 1/2 MONTHS INTO THE NEW
FISCAL YEAR.
WE'LL TAKE YOU OUT TO YUMA,
ARIZONA.
LOOK AT THIS PHOTO.
BORDER PATROL AGENTS IN THE OPEN
DESERT EAST OF YUMA PATROLLING
FIND TWO ABANDONED BACKPACKS ON
THE GROUND.
THEY ARE FULL OF METH.
90 POUNDS OF METH WORTH OVER
$150,000 ON THE STREETS.
DROPPED AND ABANDONED BY
SUSPECTED DRUG SMUGGLERS.
THERE ARE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
TRYING TO BACKPACK THE STUFF
INTO OUR COUNTRY.
WE'LL TAKE YOU OUT TO THE TUCSON
SECTOR.
THESE WILD PHOTOS.
AGENTS PULLED OVER A VEHICLE
NEAR WILLCOX, ARIZONA AFTER IT
TRIED TO GET AROUND THE
CHECKPOINT ON THE HIGHWAY.
THEY FIND NINE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS PILED ON TOP OF EACH
OTHER IN THE LITTLE S.U.V.
BEING SMUGGLED.
TWO U.S. CITIZENS DRIVING THAT
VEHICLE.
THEY WERE BOTH ARRESTED AND
CHARGED WITH HUMAN SMUGGLING.
LASTLY WE'LL TAKE YOU TO THE
TUCSON SECTOR AGAIN IN ARIZONA
WHERE AGENTS ENCOUNTERED FOUR
SEPARATE GROUPS TOTALING 350
PEOPLE.
WHAT MAKES THESE PHOTOS
INTERESTING IS ALL THE PEOPLE
YOU ARE SEEING HERE, THEY WERE
FROM 12 DIFFERENT COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD.
YUMA SECTOR HAD FIVE GROUPS FROM
46 COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD.
GOES TO SHOW PEOPLE ARE COMING
IN FROM ALL OVER THE PLACE.
LASTLY, BACK OUT HERE LIVE
BORDER PATROL IN THE RIO GRANDE
VALLEY ANNOUNCING LATE YESTERDAY
AFTERNOON THEIR AGENTS ARRESTED
TWO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WITH
MURDER CONVICTIONS INCLUDING ONE
CONVICTED OF MURDERING A PEACE
OFFICER IN LOS ANGELES AND
ANOTHER WHO WAS CONVICTED OF
MURDER IN THE STATE OF VIRGINIA.
GUYS, THAT IS WHY IT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO HAVE AGENTS OUT ON
THE FRONT LINES AND WHY IT IS SO
CONCERNING WHEN WE HAD MORE THAN
73,000 KNOWN GOTAWAYS AT OUR
BORDER LAST MONTH ALONE.
WE'LL SEND IT BACK TO YOU.
>> Dana: I HAVE A QUICK QUESTION
FOR YOU.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO YOU EVERY
DAY OR IF IT'S GRIFF OR ALEXIS
OR NATE, WHOEVER IS DOWN
REPORTING EVERY DAY.
OFTEN YOU ARE THE ONLY REPORTER
DOWN THERE.
IT LOOKS TO BE THAT'S PERHAPS
CHANGING A LITTLE BIT.
DO YOU GET THE SENSE THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND, THE OTHER MEDIA
UNDERSTANDS THIS IS A HUGE,
HISTORIC MOMENT, A BIG STORY
THEY NEED TO BE ON TOP OF?
>> I THINK THEY MIGHT FINALLY
STARTING TO BE WAKING UP TO IT
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED IN EL
PASO THIS WEEK.
WE HAD THAT HUGE MIGRANT CARAVAN
COME IN ON SUNDAY NIGHT.
THE CITY OF EL PASO IS
COMPLETELY OVERWHELMED NOW AND
HUNDREDS OF MIGRANTS HOMELESS
LIVING ON THE STREETS IN THE
CLOSE.
THEY ARE CALLING IN AGENTS FROM
ELSEWHERE.
EVERYONE IS OVERWHELMED.
A BAD SITUATION IN EL PASO NOW
AND WHERE MOST OF THE MEDIA HAS
GONE.
THE MORE THE MERRIER WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS COVERAGE.
IT HAS BEEN A BIG ISSUE AN